الاخبار اهلا بكم رفعت الرقابه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه تعتيم العالميه على الحدث
الامنيه الذي وقع على الحدود الاسرائيليه
اللبنانيه الاثنين الماضي وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه قتل شخصا تسلل من الاراضي
اللبنانيه كان المسؤول عن تنفيذ تفجير
بعبوه الناسفه في مفترق جده جنوب حيفا
صباح الاثنين
وقال رئيس اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي انه يجب
الاستعداد لحدث على جبهات عده تشمل ايران
اكد المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
الجيش يحقق في مسؤوليه حزب الله عن هذه
العمليه
رجح المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
يكون حادث التصادم الذي وقع بين الطائره
المسيره الامريكيه ومقاتله روسيه فوق
البحر الاسود كان غير متعمد وقال برايس في
مقابله مع محطه تلفزيونيه تعتيم او
التقييم الافضل حتى الان يدل على ان
الحادث وقع بسبب انعدام الكفاءه لدى احد
الطيارين الروس حسب وصفه
قال وزير الدفاع الامريكي
بلاده ستواصل العمل في الاجواء المتاحه
لها وفق القانون الدولي واشدد على ضروره
التواصل بين واشنطن وموسكو ودع روسيا الى
تشغيل طائرتها العسكريه بطريقه امنه
ومهنيه على حد التعبير
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه وزير الدفاع
سويغو بحث هاتفيا حادثا مسيره الامريكيه
مع نظيره الامريكي بمبادره من الجانب
الامريكي واضافت الوزاره من الوزير شايغو
اكد لنظيره الامريكي
ان
الطلعات الجويه
الامريكيه قباله سواحل القرن استفزازيه
وتخلق اجواء من التصعيد
ان روسيا ستواصل الرد بشكل مناسب على جميع
الاستفزازات بالقرب من حدودها
قال رئيس شركه فاجن القوات الروسيه تسيطر
على مسيطره
في التوسع وقال موقع ريد اوف العسكريه
الروسي قد اكد ان قوات فاجنر عززت مواقعها
في مرتفعات شمال وشمال غربي بخمت
قال الرئيس الاوكرانيين الموقف بات واضحا
وهو ضروره تعزيز جبهه بخموت بالامدادات
لتدمير القوات الروسيه في الجانب الاخر
مؤكدا استمرار القتال في المدينه في هذه
الاثناء تعهدت الدول الغربيه بتزويد
اوكرانيا باكثر من 150 دبابه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه بدا في
تدريبات عسكريه ثلاثيه بين روسيا والصين
وايران في منطقه بحر العرب وقال الجيش
الايرانيين المناورات المشتركه ستتواصل
على مدى خمسه ايام من جانبها قالت وزاره
الدفاع الصينيه ان التدريبات ستساعد في
تعميق التعاون الفعلي بين القوات البحريه
للدول المشاركه
ضمن الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]